PROFESSOR: So now that we've
done a very simple calculation
of C of t, the
concentration of virions
in the air per volume,
which is coming
from just a mass balance
in a well-mixed room,
let's zoom in, now, and
think about transmission
between the infected person,
or an infected person
and then a susceptible person
who is not yet infected.
And the transmission
is occurring
by breathing the
infected droplets in,
and then the virus has to
get out of those droplets
and interact with
the host tissues.
So if we let beta be
the transmission rate,
so this is basically
new infection per time,
so basically, it's the rate
at which another person may
become infected.
Then how will we write this?
Well, we could write it as--
so we're, now, forgetting
about the infected person.
We care about their
breathing only
because it's producing this
concentration C that we just
talked about.
But now we're going to focus
on the susceptible person.
The susceptible person is now
breathing in at the same flow
rate Qb because the breathing in
and breathing out are the same.
And so Qb is the volume
per time around, let's say,
0.5 meters cubed per hour with
which they're sampling the air.
And the air comes
in, and then C of t
is the concentration
of virions per volume.
So this combination now tells
me how many virions per time
they're actually taking in.
There'll be a quantity Ci, which
we mentioned earlier, which
is the infectivity, and
that's the probability
that an individual
virion actually
causes this person to
get sick and to become
infected themselves.
So this is the infectivity
of an individual virion.
And then on top of that,
we also want to put in--
I'll just change the
color to highlight it--
the mask factor that we
talked about earlier.
So that's the transmission
or penetration probability
for the droplets of
interest through the mask.
These quantities, many of
them will depend on size,
and we'll come to that,
size of the droplet,
but just as a rough
approximation,
this is the starting point.
So this is the number of,
basically, new infections
per time, and there
is a useful notion
in epidemiology, which is
that of the infection quantum.
So transmission rates
are often written
as infection quanta
per time, and that
is the rate at which a
person, which is susceptible,
will get infected.
What we have not yet
captured is if you
have a finite number
of people in the room,
when someone gets infected,
they can't get infected again.
So the numbers of susceptible
people is changing.
So we have to model the
progression of the disease
in the room, which
we have not done yet.
So that's why the beta is not
the number of infected people
cause eventually you run
out of people to infect.
So we have to account
for that later.
But a useful way
to think of it is
that beta is sort of the rate
at which this person is sending
infection quanta over here.
Those quanta may not
actually lead to an infection
because they might already
have been infected.
But if they're
susceptible, that tells you
the rate at which that
person would become infected.
So that's the notion
of infection quanta
is essentially defined by
the transmission rate beta.
Now, this infectivity is
something we'll come back to.
We will actually go through
the calculation for SARS-CoV-2,
but it's been estimated
before to be at about 2%
from the original
SARS virus in 2003.
And in fact, I will argue
that it's greater than 10%
for SARS-CoV-2.
And we'll do that by analyzing
spreading data with the model.
And, of course, that
helps to explain
why SARS-CoV-2 has led
to the COVID-19 pandemic,
and SARS-CoV-1 was not
able to spread as much.
So now we have here
our transmission rate.
And we can ask ourselves, this
is a transmission rate, which
is time-dependent,
but what if now
we calculate the steady-state
transmission rate?
So the transient would be
when the infected person first
enters the room.
The concentration is
changing in time in the air,
but eventually, there's kind
of a steady-state where there's
a balance of the production
and then the flow rate
through the room of refreshing
the air with outdoor air.
And in steady-state, we
have the transmission rate
is going to go to
a constant value,
which I'll call
beta bar, and that
is given by the
steady-state concentrations.
So here I'll just write it--
I'll rewrite this expression
here Qb Ci Pm and then
the steady-state C, which is
the production rate P divided
by the outdoor airflow rate Q.
And another way we
can write that is
that remember Q we can
write as lambda a times
V. So this is Qb, and in
fact, let me-- well, here,
I'll write it one more time.
That's my Ci Pm capital
P over lambda A V.
Now, recall that the
P we had written as,
that's the production
rate, also depends
on Qb, that's the rate at which
the infected person is exhaling
infected air.
So that was Qb times nd, the
number of droplets per volume,
Vd, the volume of
liquid in a droplet,
so this nd Vd's the
volume fraction of liquid.
And then we needed Cv, which
was the concentration of virions
in the liquid or in the fluid.
And there's also a factor
of Pm if that person
is wearing a mask.
So we put all this together, we
get an important result here,
which is that the steady-state
transmission rate can
be written, when I plug-in here,
as Qb squared times Pm squared.
So the mask factor
comes in twice
because if they are wearing
masks, there's two masks.
You have a mask at the source.
You also mask at the
target, and the fluid
has to go through
both of those filters.
So that's one reason, as
we'll see, that masks can be,
actually, very effective.
And then we'll lump all
the parameters in something
I'll call Cq, which
I'll come back to,
and then we'll leave lambda
a V in the denominator.
So this is the main
transmission rate
where I've defined this
important parameter Cq which
has all the information
about the specific disease,
and what is it?
It's everything else is left.
It's nd Vd, so that has
to do with respiration,
so the distribution
of droplet sizes
and the size of the
droplets is something
that's coming from the
type of respiration
that the infected
person is engaging in.
Cv is their viral
load, so it has
to do with the progression
of their disease
and how many viruses
or virions are found.
And then we have Ci,
which is this infectivity,
the probability that
any one of those virions
will actually infect
this susceptible person
if it manages to get in
there and diffuse out
of the droplets.
So coming back to this
notion of infection quanta,
while beta is an infection
quanta per time, which
are being kind of transmitted
from one infected person to one
susceptible person, the
way I've written it here
is I've reexpressed it as
infection quanta per volume
of air exhaled.
So while C is the concentration
of virions in the background,
there is this Cq, which is
essentially the infection
quanta that are being released,
and the factor of CvCi
is actually what
connects those two.
In fact, sometimes we
write Cq little cq CvCi,
this is infection quanta
per liquid volume in a drop.
So from the mucus or material
that's being released,
there is a certain concentration
of infection quanta, which
is the physical concentration
of the virions Cv
times the probability
that if they
were to be exposed to the
susceptible person's cells,
that they would actually
infect those cells
and cause a transmission
of the infection.
So that's another
important quantity,
and this here is really
the primary sort of lumped
or combined disease
and physiological
parameter in the model.
So what's nice about
separating this way is
that Qb is something which has
to do with people's activity,
it's how fast they're
breathing, and that's
something we know very easily
whether they're at rest
or they're exercising.
Pm is also known if we know
the kinds of masks people
are wearing.
There's various studies
of transmission factors
and filtration
efficiencies of masks.
And so we can put
reasonable estimates there.
And then here we
see the importance
of lambda a, which is
the air exchange rate.
So how quickly is fresh
air coming in the room?
That's a physical
parameter of the room, has
nothing to do with the disease.
And V, of course, is a
geometrical parameter,
the room, which is the volume.
And so all the disease aspects
are kind of lumped into the Cq.
So if I want to apply this to
actual spreading of COVID-19,
I have all these
parameters that I
know that come from
the physics and fluid
mechanics of the room.
And then, I have a
single parameter Cq
that I need to obtain from
an understanding of disease
transmission and looking
at spreading events
in indoor situations.